so the guy goes you know we just got to
get back on the saddle and next year's
our yearly and I can't stand what people
do they go you you what do you mean what
do you mean we you you know we we had a
hard game you know and we we just got
them at you you keep saying we I'm like
you don't rinse right now you're gonna
training camp I don't how did you a big
sign use a free agent laughter super I'm
confused
cuz you live in LA and you keep saying
we I'm and you play safety support you
can be a backstab back there get that
block those passes I'm safety support
you outside roving safety so we're
little safety we have a tough get yeah
hey man yeah here hey bro it's fanatical
its finale and I don't I love fans I
love that they are that way but what
buzz about when people go oh you would
have zero friends if you only liked
people who cheered for the Steven Seagal
did stid when they were out to talking
about Anderson Silva he said we got
ready for this fight we're ready have
yeah cuz you got a bit of a belly very
game and missing any meals so I don't
think you made weight I mean he was
literally gone weak we're ready we've
been training hard hey do I get all the
time to like you up fabric Kenny getting
breakfast guy goes you play for the boss
sir I'm like hey guys you know what we
just gotta like I'm sorry on the
coaching staff I don't I'm [ __ ]
confused right now trying to finish when
I have a caller toast I'm not part of
the team so when you say we um I don't
play form does it bother you when men go
got a surprise for you
god I'll play it I'll play the guy ready
yeah hey Brendon I'm surprised way oh
yeah
we're pregnant and it's so exciting your
dick I'm gonna throw you in a flying
headlock and beat the [ __ ] out of you
here yeah yeah I want to go get a full
like a full [ __ ] crazy you should
have had 50 for sure I should right yeah
I just wanted get on top of things yeah
that's when the cancer so I gotta get I
gotta get myself a colonoscopy you gotta
get a camera right up my [ __ ] got I
told you [ __ ] around the yeah check you
know what your big things your prostate
I feel like yours all right though my
process we gots time they check that a
year ago had his finger run up my ass
one finger I don't remember but it was
terrible and he had big hand only one
finger though yeah I think so and he
said to avoid well any weight you know
what he did when he got it my my [ __ ]
he goes he pulled out poopie no there's
no poopy I don't think but he goes flat
as a pancake I'd say it said about my
prostate flat as a pancake well I guess
well we're good I don't like that [ __ ] I
do not it's the work has to be easier
way to chill oh why do you gotta stick
your finger in my ass seriously I don't
like it man and don't talk to me while
you're doing it just say here goes here
goes nothing they really lube up those
gloves God he ran attention I have give
me I doubt the chew on it was difficult
because I couldn't relax you kept saying
you gotta just relax
Oh every time you try to go in I
puckered up like a constrictor and I was
instinct I couldn't I wonder if I know
what was gonna say I know if I constrict
hard enough if he's like hey hey I'm
done I'm like uh-uh not today
hey I'm done like not on my watch buddy
you know this nurse he's oh god damn it
this pain comes off there's just trapped
in there he's like hey hey man I'm like
uh-uh uh-uh
are you screaming Chinese Han cops no
nothing Chinese Hancock I'm just like
you earned in this today you can earn
this results are you so big you earned
in this you're in this throughout June
and you're going yeah keep on and you
can hear his knuckles popping it's just
like and I'm like come on man wait he's
putting a little [ __ ] heat in there
we got some an online little heat in
there you got why do you keep you
bringing your hips forward because I'm
clenching my like a scared dog no I'm
scared dog I'm watching my ass cheeks
like call tucking the tail good like you
know it's called tucking the tail good
luck
and since he's not gonna see me again
took in the tail Turner I wonder if
that's possum you ain't going nowhere
cuz like if I was in prison that's all I
would focus on it's like that hip thrust
oh my god you put it in there good luck
getting out yeah and I come now I'm
gonna run out all the homies you know
you [ __ ] me in the ass and for no
reason I'm gonna armbar your dick my
[ __ ]
there you go and I come in and I go honk
and I start giving you a honk check for
no reason with them without looking him
in the eye going ha ha go honk honk and
I'm going Jonny's handcuffs he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] is going on
well you know it's funny about
intellectuals I've done a little study
on them they tend to be a little bit
corny with their humor and then I
realize he said well you're probably
just some old lady who reads books in a
dusty closet and the problem was a lot
of it was true it's hard to laugh at
stuff that isn't funny yeah we do and he
has he has both his arm sleeved I just
have one sleeved there you go he's a
handsome serial killers to be real here
handsome murder yeah I was in I was in
Ralph's and this is when he was going
through it when he they just like
apprehended that [ __ ] killer and I
swear there's a black guy behind me and
he's on the phone he's gone
nah man I'm looking at this [ __ ]
right now now he's in not [ __ ]
here now he's out dog I swear to God
Hernandez is in front of me buying
[ __ ] of Red Vines and I turn around
like what now [ __ ] and he thought I was
in [ __ ] Hernandez hilarious
true story and when I was doing Tim
Tebow's foundation every year even last
year when this [ __ ] office Lee
in prison
people are like Hernandez you know
people aren't UFC fans obviously I'm not
that famous when I go by Lee like it's
in and dead serious I'm like god damn it
that would be the one time people were
mistaking you for sure because I'm at
Florida I'm with Tim Tebow and people
were still like a Hernandez and this is
when [ __ ] on trial for murder
multiple murders it mind if I your
autograph
like you're sick you are [ __ ] sick
hey you'd be like hey I know you kill
all those people who throws harder Tom
Brady or Tim Tebow like get the [ __ ] out
of my face
the answer is Tim Tebow like it's like
it's like if we if we if I pull down my
loaf I'd be like yeah Bryan Callen and
then there's like it's like there's a
little noise Brian Cowen puts his loaf
on the table like that and then the
gringo mandingo puts is this like you
kept the cracking good
you caught the grit and you caught
although the heavy dusting that DNA [ __ ]
with ancestry doctor up not really it
just went there's a waste of time no
[ __ ] you find out any information
nothing I thought they had girl in you
yeah a tad bit of a gorilla a little bit
of grilling they said like like like we
can't identify this but we know it's
some sort of simian it was some [ __ ]
cuz it was literally like it was like
all over it was literally like I'm like
well [ __ ] and what about you you know
what dude you guys did it right yeah
that's at your house your wife you said
it I have the spirit of an Apache uh you
know what I mean and the mercantilism of
a southern Italian I'm a merchant I'll
say anything huh yeah huh so what are
you man what the [ __ ] and what are you
Italian Irish an Italian so it's an
Irish and Italian that's why I have such
a such fire in my belly and such outrage
at the injustice of the world it's why
I'll hug you and punch at the same time
I'm a walking contradiction to sour
patch kids yeah I'm actually to be
honest with you I'm art in motion and
that's that's not me saying it that's
the New York Times I'm a comet raveling
comic okay so you got back late from
where the people in Austin wanted me so
I had to give them I had to give them
from from Wednesday to Saturday
I gave why couldn't you make it back I
couldn't get an early flight so as they
tear my clothes that I can't go to the
airport like what everybody's there by
these less private hahaha you have to
like going to the sky like a Groucho
Maurice Clarett he's taller in person is
he an athlete as well yeah I get a lot
of that stuff so they want to touch they
want they want to get involved what the
secret is at 50 years old are you kid
look at my face at 50 at 50 why what I'm
sorry I'm v how old are you rap 46 yeah
and I look good a good 16 years you
[ __ ] telling yourself yeah look at my
look at
what